welcome everyone to our thursday
um demise research conference and
um as you know we've been
uh trying to bring in speakers from
outside
as much as we would love to someday have
them visit our campus but this also
gives us a chance to hear from them and
perhaps makes a little easier and that
they
don't need to travel although some of us
like to travel in any case it gives me
great pleasure today to
welcome dr kendrick cato who a number of
you know
is an assistant professor at
the new york presbyterian medical center
in columbia university
school of nursing he also has an
appointment in the department
of emergency medicine at the irving
medical
center dr cato
is originally trained as a nurse
um has a bachelor's and master's degree
the latter is a nurse practitioner from
colombia
and then obtained in 2014 a phd
in biomedical informatics from the great
program at columbia he's continued on
working since then as a faculty
and has
done a variety of projects i i won't
cut too much into his time by talking
about them
but his most recent work is a study
called concern which he's going to talk
about today
which aims to use machine learning data
analytics other
advanced data science methods to
improve the practice environment for
nurses in the hospital
so i will let him um
tell us more about it as as usual
uh people are encouraged to leave their
cameras on although
it is the lunch hour including for
myself so um some of us might
disappear behind this screen so you
don't have to watch us
eat our lunch but if you can
it's great to have your camera on so i
will
turn it over to dr cato and we'll go
from there
so thank you so much um for the
introduction um
i'm very excited as i was saying earlier
it's nice to be
presenting to some folks that um i know
and i wish that i look forward to the
day when we see each other again
um at a informatics conference
um and so uh my name is kendra cato i'm
going to talk a little bit about well
i'm i'm going to start off this
presentation with an introduction to the
concern
study which uh which the work that i'm
going to be talking about is based on
and then um just and then dive into some
stuff that we've learned about
bias in nursing workflow
and so i have no conflicts to disclose
and so
the concern study and then i hope we'll
have some time
at the end for questions um so the
concern study
is a nih-funded study it's actually a
six-year study with a randomized
controlled trial at the end
and we're in the randomized controlled
trial phase of the study right now
um and what concern stands for is
communicating narrative concerns entered
by registered nurses
and this is a multi-pi study um
sarah rossetti who spoke to your group i
think two weeks ago
is one of the principal investigators
and i am the other principal
investigator
um and um
it is multi-site between columbia
university
and harvard medical school
between most of our work is being done
at brigham
women's hospital in newton-wellesley and
um
the the hospital the actual clinical
setting here columbia is at the columbia
university irving medical center
um to hospitals in in that
system and so this is just our team
between two sites and we're really
uh you know very blessed to have also a
great advisory board
for this study so um just a little bit
of background so this study is really
this is an inpatient study um so we're
working
in the inpatient setting and um
and what this study is really about
is um clinical deterioration and
detecting
uh risk for clear clinical deterioration
uh in the inpatient setting
so we know that um a lot of folks die in
the inpatient setting and some of those
deaths are considered
preventable if clinicians would act
sooner
we also know from some work that sarah
and i have done almost a decade now that
the nurses um because they spend
most of the time with patients they
detect subtle changes um
in patient clinical state and uh
they they change their surveillance
surveillance based on that and when i
say surveillance
i mean you know the amount of attention
that a nurse pays to
pays to a patient we also know um
that the physician expectation
of so physician's expectation
of deterioration of clinical states is
slightly different um
in nursing observations and there's
there isn't very good communication
between nurses and physicians about
the change in clinical state and what i
mean more specifically about that is
that
um because of the way our health care
system systems set up right now
physicians typically have to take care
of a lot of patients and so
when a nurse is concerned about a
patient and they contact the clinician
often if there aren't physiological
changes
there are other patients who have
physiological changes
that are at a higher priority in the
long list of patients that
say a resident has to take care of and
so um
that communication of physiolog of
concern about a patient deterioration
gets lost
because there aren't there aren't any
other um
kind of evidence-based ways to back up a
nurse's uh
concern about a patient and so um
one of the other parts of um what you
know one of the major parts of concern
has to do with
nursing notes and um
you know i'll just pose a rhetorical
question to the group but the question
is
who reads nursing notes right and and
this is an important question
because the clinical note is where a
clinician puts their expert
opinion about the um
the state the clinical state of the
patient what they're thinking about the
patient what they think um
the plan should be for the patient and
and things like that and that's supposed
to be shared
amongst interdisciplinary teams but um
some work that was done
here at columbia a while back um
shows that actually no one reads nursing
notes um and this was done by
ripsec at all in 2011 and and we just a
couple
like two three years ago two and a half
years ago we
looked at the data again and not much
had changed
and so what they found um in this work
was that
uh very few people read nursing notes
nurses don't even read nursing notes so
um almost no one outside the
out of the nursing domain read nursing
notes but even a lot of
but even after a note was written not
very many
you know i think it was um it was
something
around uh there was almost 50 percent of
the time when the
note wasn't read again um and so this
you know this is something this is just
some background that drove our work
and so um in uh
uh around 2008 2009 we started doing
work
um looking at interdisciplinary
communication
um and um and patterns of nursing
documentation and what we found was that
um that
when nurses as i mentioned are concerned
about patient deterioration there
we could detect some signals in the
electronic health record and so we did a
study looking at um
at um patients and what you see here
is just a graph from the study the
analysis
we took a group of patients that had a
rest and a group of patients that didn't
have a rest in the inpatient setting
in the med surg units and we looked at
um
at some of the just items in the hr we
found that that
um in a in a statistically significant
way
nurses were starting to do
more flow sheet observations
so take more vital signs uh you know
things like heart rate
temperature blood pressure and they were
also writing more comments so in the in
the ehr
in the flow sheet which is where nurses
do most of their documentation
uh you can enter in a value and then you
can right click
and this is in most ehr systems and
write an additional comment
and so one of the things that we found
was a strong signal for
the patients that eventually had an
arrest was the fact that
nurses chose to write a comment and this
is optional documentation this is above
and beyond
what's required and so this is really um
this was the real first publication that
sarah and i did where we really started
to kind of dig in
um to the notion of trying to model
um uh this concern for patients
and so um so what is concern so um
this is um so concern is really an early
warning system
um uh we are
trying to uh model uh
a nurse's expert uh
concern for deterioration or risk for
deterioration of patient
and provide that as clinical decision
support
um for the entire interdisciplinary team
the concern project also
so we use documentation um so we use
existing documentation so um there are
some other
early warning systems that ask
clinicians to to fill out additional
forms and things like that
um so because um we don't
do that and we use what's existing in
the hr we don't add to documentation
burden which is also something
that's important to us not just around
additional documentation burn but also
just fitting into the clinton's workflow
um
and you know the point that i'll make
here and i'll make it a couple of times
is that
concerns a little different than other
early warning systems because we're
actually trying to model
clinical expertise we're not trying to
model or
a better way of saying is we're trying
to model expert clinician
um concern for a patient's risk for
deterioration we're not trying to model
actual physiological changes in our
patient
um and so um
kind of the the theoretical framework
behind what we do
um we call healthcare process models and
and this is really
um looking at um
and we just published a paper about this
in in jamie earlier this year
um really trying to model out the
healthcare process
and and this um this approach you know
we're applying healthcare process model
models for
um concern about patient deterioration
but when you try to
model um the process um there are other
processes that you could model
um and so we've we've done we've
actually during covid the last
the surgery had um in new york la this
time last year
we um used the concern approach to model
out
what level of care a clinic a patient
was at a bed because we had beds
changing
uh daily the level of care so so we use
this approach to see if a patient
in a bed was being treated as an icu
patient or if they're being treated as a
med surg
patient for example um and so um
really what it really models is is
basically the
the individual decisions that a
clinician makes about a patient
and then inherent in our process is we
we take a machine learning
approach to the data and then we take it
back to clinicians to get
domain expertise even though on our team
we have physicians and nurses um we
still go back to
practicing clinicians at the bedside um
to to then
loop back to our modeling and
adjust our our thresholds and things
like that based on their feedback
so um uh it is important um i
i pointed out that um that uh
we have um uh
the documentation that i mentioned
things like notes
they are um optional i mean not notes
i'm sorry
comments that's optional documentation
and so um
you know where we see things like um
the method the model or the machine that
we built um
it's not just looking at um
you know the fact that there are ten
more
observations for this patient than
another it's also looking at
um it's also using you know some of the
time varying aspects
of ehr data so we actually model we
we have modeling where we're looking at
every hour and thinking about and doing
prediction for every hour
thinking about what's what what makes
sense for the features
and and the model every hour and the
reason i bring that up is because
there are then um time-based
uh relationships that are important so
for example
um when uh when a nurse wakes up
a med surg patient up at three in the
morning or two in the morning to take
uh vitals uh take a
temperature blood pressure is probably
um
the nurse is probably concerned about
that patient um and so that's where the
timing comes in there's
there is a curiosity to what happens
during a shift
both for any um any clinical domain
you're talking about
and so we can find um we look at those
distributions
um and and look at the variance in those
distributions as well
and so that's what i mean when i talk
about the metadata
um we're not just looking at the we
don't really look at the values we're
also looking at the timing
of information um and
and that's you know that's what uh that
healthcare process
kind of analysis gives us and so um
there is bias right um that is important
to us
um because this you know this talk is
going to end talking about bias and
nursing workflow
and that bias that provides the signals
for
risk stratification are some of the
biases that i mentioned so
there is bias in when patients are
getting observations
there is a normal distribution when you
look at the distribution
uh when you visualize the distributions
for example you'll see that
for the most part nurses chart at a
certain time of their shift
for the most part medications are given
at certain points there's like three
peaks in most shifts
and uh and observations kind of line up
with those three peaks and so
so those types of biases matter
things like optional documentation one
of those
when a nurse decides to write more notes
or the note is longer than
than than usual that is a strong signal
and so we do leverage those biases
and so i mentioned our predictive models
so these are
just a high level kind of description of
the
uh how we we then extract features
into our modeling so we look at vital
sign comment frequencies and i mentioned
the comments of those
observational those those when you
right-click and add like a little sticky
note
we look at uh medication the medication
and mission wreck
uh administration record uh so what we
call the mar
and we have found signals in when prn
medications are given um and when
medications are withheld
um when when and a nurse is the one who
decides to do that
um uh um we are doing natural language
processing on
the content of nodes so we we did a
whole
um kind of program research
where we went to clinicians and said
what are the concerning concepts
if you saw this concept and we use the
standard terminology called the ccc
which is a nursing class clinical
classification
uh terminology that maps to snomed and
it has concepts and so we went to
different nurses between here and
harvard and said
if you see this concept or if you write
this concept in a note
with this concept mean that you're
concerned about deterioration
and so we then took those concepts and
found those concepts in
using natural language processing of the
notes and those are some of the features
that we use we do use demographic
information
um we look at how often the node is
written as well
and um how often vital signs um
the the the cumulative amount of um
vital signs that are putting in and this
is um
you know proxy for observations and
surveillance uh clinicians doing
um we did do a lot of
user-centered design interview center
design originally we were planning to
create a concerned score
and um and what what
clinicians told us was that they wanted
levels so we have uh low medium and high
and we also optimized our modeling
nurses or both nurses and physicians
said that
concern would only be helpful
uh if we optimize the modeling to
display as many of the medium risk
patients as possible because
when a patient is of low risk for
deterioration
it's it's it's kind of it's not as
important and then when someone is
showing signs of deterioration
uh clinicians probably already know um
so
so we do optimize our scoring to um
to show the folks that are at an
increased risk for deterioration
um and concern actually has two parts
there's a front end part
that i'll show you in a second our
dashboard and then we have our back end
decision engine which is taking all
those features that i mentioned
um every hour and we're um
you know we're scaling it we're doing um
it's right it's running through our
model um and then
we are then assigning a concern level
we do actually create a score one to ten
and that's just for the front end so
that
the front end logic it's easier for them
to do
uh kind of rule-based uh stuff on the
front end
when we send the score back to the ehr
um and so this is what um
this is what concern looks like um in
the ehr so there's a column
in the patient list when we did our
focus groups
um we were told that uh
that the best place to put this you know
we wanted to know how we could best fit
into the workflow the clinical workflow
both nurses and physicians said um
we want this in our patient list because
we go to the patient in a slot
and so it is a column in the patient
list and this is an
epic this is an epic and we are both
partners and columbia new york
presbyterian we're on epic
um the configuration in epic is that
they look at the
concern score and based on criteria
it will show excuse me either
a green yellow or red icon um
and you see here there's also an
asterisk what the asterisk indicates
is that um the concern score has changed
for the last hour so every hour we
calculate concern score
so this is a really easy way for
clinicians just when they're
doing their work they're going to the
patient list to see if there are any new
labs any new orders
any things like that they'll see the
concern score
and they'll see an asterisk if it's
changed if a clinician wants to find out
more information
about the patient they can click on the
icon and it will bring them
into our dashboard or what we call the
front-end app
now this is a um firebase app and so
fire if you haven't heard about it it's
just a
standard for restful apis
to pull and push data back and forth
between um
the fire server uh ehr and and the app
and so um so what we're doing here is
um uh we're pulling data um
and uh we have you know the usual stuff
you see
um and this is opening up in epic in a
window
on top of the patient list we have the
usual banner stuff so you can know it's
the right patient but it's it's a
one-to-one contact so it's showing for
the patient you clicked on
this is the that's what the information
you're going to get
we show the risk um we also have a
trended um
trended display of the risk over time um
and so you can toggle for different look
back times
and then also the the the center here
what we call the factors is something
that um
we've worked a lot on and quite frankly
we're still
working on we're struggling with and
what
what we and what the factors is it
serves for
two purposes one concern is actually
really about
improving communication between
clinicians right
so both physicians and nurses wanted to
be able to show
and see what is driving the current
concern score so
so you can see here this grey line shows
um so we took
the the features that we're using and we
we have a whole bunch of features in the
model
and we broke them down into buckets
basically
and we're doing some what if analysis to
show um
what's contributing um to the current
concern level and this line this gray
line indicates how much it's
contributing
and so you know if you're a physician
you see the nursing content is
no content is contributing you can click
on it it'll show you the nursing notes
uh more recent to uh uh oldest
and and you can actually read the notes
and so then when you when you have a
conversation with the nurse
you can um know you know um what's in
the notes
um and so it improves communication that
way and that's true
um for nurses who also want to look at
um
at stuff that happened uh you know in
prior shifts
we also show um one so two things i
didn't mention we actually have
two different models we have a icu model
and an acute care model which is med
surg so those are two different models
um that we we built separately because
the workflow is different in the icu
and in the med surg setting um things
tend to happen faster
patients deteriorate faster patients
that are different acuity level in the
icu so we actually have two
two different models working and and the
model knows what setting you're in
um that it applies to the patient um
also we do have right now for the
randomized control
trial we do have exclusion units so
we're not doing concern in oncology
setting
we're not doing concern in inpatient
mental health
we're not doing concern in the neuro
neurological icu
because the workflow is very different
and so
and also uh we also exclude patients
that
have a do not resuscitate uh do not
intubate order
active and we also exclude patients that
are on hospice
um because the workflow around
the concern for deterioration is
different um
and so um we also show like where a
patient is at that hour based on their
setting
and the distribution of patients um a
concern level
and we can you can also link in the
dashboard
to uh we have a video that explains what
it is and
some of our recent manuscripts stuff
like that so that's the concern app
we also created a dashboard for managers
up at partners they wanted to roll up
by unit to see what the levels are and
this was not the nurses wanted to um the
nursing leadership wanted this
and this is helping them with staffing
decisions
in real in more real time so i'm gonna
transition
here to um some of the things that we've
learned
um uh and and um
and and i have to say that um
a lot of this work was not um
some of the things that we learned a lot
of this had to do with
uh when i was going into the data and
just doing quality checks
um actually using nicole's framework
that she's published
just trying to make sure looking at the
data quality
um and so um
one of the first things that popped out
is there is bias in levels of nursing
surveillance so
um and when i say surveillance you know
we're looking at um
the numbers of observations taken um
notes are written no
content for patients that ended up
deteriorating so
um so there is bias in that um
um also um our modeling approach um
matters um and so um
uh i'll talk a little bit about that in
a second um
um and so if i uh and then
um we also compared um
concern to some other early warning
scores and we did find that there was
bias
in um how some of those scores
actually performed based on race um
and then you know we when we found bias
we
adjusted our scoring to make sure that
we um
reduce the actual bias in the concerned
levels based on the bias that we saw in
nursing behavior um
so uh the first so so i did a couple
i i did a couple of different analyses
um i did and our team have done um and
some of this stuff
i think actually all of the stuff that
i'm showing you now is stuff that we
haven't
we're actively working on manuscripts
for we haven't published yet
um so just to give you caveat about that
um
so one of the things that we did was i
was actually kind of curious to see if
we could find um
we could just out of the box
apply some machine learning uh to
observations and see if we could uh
if the if the machine could could
actually um
classify patients um
based on observations so what we did was
we um
and what i'm going to show you is a
preliminary analysis we're working on a
much more
detailed analysis right now but the um
um to make it a little bit more rigorous
but we're still getting uh
similar findings but what we did was we
took the first 24 hours of
observations for a patient their first
24 hours
um in the hospital um either their first
24 hours on a med search unit or the
first 24 hours in icu
and we looked at all the observations
just cumulatively um
and we we um and when i say observations
we're talking about flowsheet
observations here and we um
wanted to see if um if uh
the machine could classify the patient's
race
um which obviously is not in the data
set
so so this is just um so you can see
here this is just some of the um
the results that we got um uh
not doing a lot of work um to improve
the modeling so
so there is a signal so what we've um
you know
kind of shown is that there is a signal
um
and you know these aren't you know if
you're building a classifier this isn't
super great um uh performance but there
is a signal
in the observations um by race um
and what we the the the further work we
did is we actually um
have added comorbidities um and we've
reduced um we reduced the sample size to
um just the three top um discharge
diagnoses
um in our in our hospital
um primary diet primary discharge
diagnosis
and um and so we're re-running the
analysis
right now and we're also just looking
we're looking at med search units and
we're also looking at
the medical icu we took out the other
icus because we know that for example in
the surgical icu
surgeons tend to not do surgery unless
it's emergency surgery but they tend to
not do surgery outpatient they're
selective
about what they do surgery on and so um
and and so there is some bias in that
selection as well
and then you know what you see here in
this uh
shapley diagram is these are actually
the observation
ids um so um so
uh the so there are you know ids
there are flow sheet ids flowsheet items
that contributed
more to um you know kind of the
explainability of what
which of these features help in the
classification
um and so the the
next thing i wanted to show you is um
uh you know when we were doing our
scoring
um for concern um we found that there
was
um a bias in the concerned scoring so
what this
is is an analysis um so basically what
we did was we took 9000 patients
at columbia and we um
we looked at um uh
their race so uh the different lines
here are different races so blue is
white uh orange is black
um yellow is uh unknown and
in our sample set most of the unknown
patients
are just in other work we've done
there's a high proportion of
hispanic patients who
eventually end up categorizing
themselves as black um
uh in in in this group and then this is
asian
um we exclu there are other
uh there are there are other populations
that there are very many of like native
american
that we excluded from the analysis and
so um
so what we did was we calculated the
difference between
um so the proportion of patients
based on concern levels and so zero
is is yellow 2
is i'm sorry 0 is green 2 is yellow
and 3 is red and this was what
the concern model was scoring for these
patients
and and we found that um for patients
that
ended up deteriorating um
that uh white patients um
so the odds so when you look at the
actual impact um
they were they were almost nine times as
likely to get a red score
um and blacks were
almost nine times less likely to get a
red score
um when they should have gotten a red
score and for asians it was almost
even when you look at at red
and this and it's it's smaller for uh
yellow but you can see there's also
there's also this
um this difference here and so this you
know this told us that we had to adjust
our the actual score from the model
um when we generated the score so so we
did
employ uh an adjustment and i'll speak
to that
in a little bit um when we're actually
generating the concern score
um the last analysis that we did was um
we were actually
very curious to see um how concerned
we were comparing concern to some of the
other early warning scores and so
uh we compared it to the news and the
muse
um and um
[Music]
we looked at um one of the criteria so
so we're looking at
at concern and we actually took um
we compared black patients to white
patients um
and their scoring um and
what we found when we looked at um the
concerned score and this is just in the
icu setting
um what we found when we looked at the
distribution
and the concerned scoring for patients
who had a yellow score um
there was no statistical difference
between blacks and whites
um but when we looked at the news and
the muse
and this is you know their kind of
medium scoring level there was a
statistically different
um uh scoring um
for both for in both the news and the
muse and so um
and so the thing that um i want to
emphasize about the difference between
concern and the news and the muse is
that we are
the news and the muse actually use
physiological
values um and concern
is different in that um it doesn't so
that's one of the
that's something that's that's really
important to point out
about um how the actual scoring works
um for those um
for those systems are those
calculations so um
so in summary
um you know we were able to detect
um bias in
um nursing workflow um
that and and we use nursing workflow
for our concern work um and you know so
it is important
to um
that that there is racial there is bias
in in when um nurses are concerned about
a patient
and we exploit that but there's also
racial bias
in levels of nursing surveillance um
and then also you know your modeling
approach matters
um um and so
uh we um
one of the things that we did so future
directions so um
we actually went back so
we went back and adjusted our scoring
there are two ways you could
two ways that we looked at adjusting
scoring one was um
either changing the modeling itself uh
so adjusting it
in when trying to to adjust the modeling
uh to um to reduce the bias and workflow
or
adjust the scoring um and we decided to
adjust the scoring
so we actually adjust the scores based
on on what we found
um are the proportions between expected
and
actual um surveillance
um and so we add that into our
post-processing
after we get uh
after it runs through the model um and
then
um for us you know we weren't
i wasn't planning to really do a lot of
work
around bias in nursing workflow um
you know we weren't thinking about it
our racial bias looked to do a lot of
work in racial bias uh nursing workflow
when we submitted this grant
seven years ago um uh
but it's clear that um you know to me uh
when a clinician is not um
surveilling patients at equal levels
that there's
that i categorize it as missed care and
so
as someone who does clinical decision
support it's important to me to
help support clinical decision making
and so we're working on a grant right
now
to uh to basically see how we can
give information back how we can provide
clinical decision support
um to say that there is missed care
based on
your level of surveillance um you know
what would be
where would that fit in the workflow
what would be the most effective way of
providing that information back to
clinicians
and seeing if that actually has um an
effect on on some of the bias that we
found
um in the work um and so
um so that's uh that's the
basically our plan for future directions
um and so uh we have an r1 that's going
to be going
going in later this summer uh on that
work
and so um i
i would be remiss if i didn't uh again
acknowledge
the work of our team because the the
stuff that i've shown you
um has been done not just by me but our
entire team
and so um you know i'm
very very humbled and happy to have to
work
with the folks um both on our advisory
board but also
the team up at partners and uh the team
at columbia
um and so i'm gonna wrap up now
uh so that we can have some time for
questions so
thank you um i see that there's uh
that there is one question already in
the chat about um
and i don't you know feel free to on
feel free to um
unmute yourself i would love to hear
your question
um there is a question about how often
we um we calculate the concern score
so what we do is um i'm sorry how often
we update the concern score
so we're actually um one of the things i
didn't mention is in the background
we are using control theory to look at
um
the levels of of the features that we're
pulling in
so there is great concern
and that pun is intended um amongst
our clinicians especially physicians
that nurses will game the system
and um and uh write more notes
take more observations write more
comments to get more attention
about a patient um i my
where i sit and we've had i've had a lot
of conversations with folks about this
where uh the team i could say this is my
view and our team's view
is that nurses um
the primary part of a nurse's job is to
um
is to identify which patients are in
need of additional help
um and if the concern tool helps them do
that
i don't see nurses frivolously
trying to get clinicians to come see a
patient that they're not concerned about
so it's not a big concern of mine but um
but i said but in saying that we do have
we do have control theory analysis
running in the background that's looking
at the levels um over time
and trying to understand if those levels
of those the levels of the features and
if they've changed
significantly um to what we expect
and we do have um we do have
um built into the trial um
uh actual times where we will update the
model
um uh based on on any
and and and change the thresholds of the
model based on
on any features that we see going out of
of the levels um that we've set
um and so um and
and that is basically we have it and
that's not you know that's taking into
account
just regular fixes like if something
isn't working um
uh and that's we we do that on two-month
cycle
in the in the uh in the randomized
control trial and
the trial runs for a year um um
what i would say also is you know if
you've ever worked with ehr data there
is
constant change in the hr configuration
and so we also
um are doing work where we're
looking to see so for example um
someone will add a new vital sign in one
subunit like the cardiac icu for example
and that vital sign because we're using
fire
the way they have it configured the fire
server is not pulling
that vital sign in as a vital sign so
um we're constantly looking at new new
observations are coming and trying to
decide
if that's an observation that fits into
the criteria of what we're looking for
and then those updates we're doing all
the time
we just do them when we can um to to map
new new features that are coming in that
that makes sense to us so
i hope i answered that question yeah
yeah and and mina can can answer back in
the chat and i imagine other people are
um also wanting uh to ask questions so
we
um people can um on mute to ask
questions and by the way
um one of the quirks of webex is
sometimes when you stop screen sharing
it turns your video
off um so your video's off which which
if you want to keep it sorry i didn't i
didn't real no no no i didn't realize
that thank you bill for pointing that
out
but uh if i can ask um a question so
um um your your randomized control trial
originally was um basically looking at
whether the
concern score led to having that
available led to improvements in patient
care
as i understand patients yeah
yeah so the primary outcomes for a
randomized controlled trial are
inpatient mortality and length of stay
so those are the the major outcomes
we have second we have a lot of outcomes
or other things they're interested in
but um you know the other secondary
outcomes that we have
you know that we promise you now each we
look at are um
are things like readmission rates um
and um we're also interested in what
clinicians do
after what clinicians do
after they see a certain concern
level as well so we're interested in the
behavior
of clinicians um after they so
and and we have logging in we have
logging in in the
in the app so that we can see what what
they actually
look at those different sections and
links
we get logging to see what clinicians
are actually doing
um and so we're looking at that as well
great so so then a corollary would be um
have and i guess maybe if this trial is
still underway you might not know this
but then um
does the racial bias in the the workflow
and the instrument
um um impact uh patient outcomes
um or is that something you plan to look
at yeah that's something we plan to look
at
we're not looking at that yet um we are
doing an interim analysis right now so
one
so what i didn't mention also was that
um
we went live um at
we went live up at partners before so
the original plan was to to go live
at the same time at both sites um
but our um in between when we got this
study
um and we're doing kind of the the
preliminary aims which was just like
improving modeling and doing the
the focus groups um here at columbia
in the whole new york presbyterian
health system they decided we were in
all scripts at the time they decided to
go
epic so the epic implementation happened
last year
that pushed our implementation of the
trial back
um and so um and so
the interim analysis we're doing right
now is only on the partners data because
that's been live
since last july and
one of the things we also want to know
is in an interim sense like do we see
any major changes in our primary
outcomes um or um
you know do we so we don't have an
interruptive alert
and clinicians were very
very gave us very strong feedback to say
that they did not want another alert
so that's why our clinical decision
support is
offered in in the patient list
if we if in our internal analysis we
don't see
a change in our two major outcomes
um we might consider strongly to um
add an interruptive alert so that's
something great
by the way of analysis that we're
dealing with right now
great i'll let others uh speak up i see
uh peter has raised his head
yeah please repeat raise his hand thanks
a lot it's so nice to hear
your work and your project is
fascinating um
question i had so with the bias when you
you have a model that
that gives an output of one to ten that
uh you know the
level of concern that was really trained
on a on us
on a set of people and i was wondering
whether uh
that training set was biased in terms of
numbers like
you know the population and whether you
balanced for that and whether that
may have handled the the bias that you
ended up seeing in the final result
yeah so that's a great question so in
the training so
one of the one of the really important
things for us in predictive analysis
um when we were when we were doing the
training and the scoring we actually
entered the data
in the way it would come in in real life
and you know that um you know when
you're doing modeling for
a system that's actually going to be um
it's actually going to be firing in real
life that's just something that that
folks need to
take into consideration that we found
doesn't always happen
um we actually use we actually use five
five years of historical data
um um
for all of the patients um on the types
of units that we are
looking at so there was no um uh there
was
no selection there was no curation of
the data in that sense
um we didn't you know um
the only exclusions we had um from our
training were the
types of situations that i mentioned
like patients who
are um we took out so what we did was we
took out patient patients that
eventually
um patients that went on
uh that became dnr dni or went on
hospice
we took out their data um we used their
data before
uh that happened and there there is i
can't remember the time but we did
create a grace period a little bit
beforehand um
um but but we didn't um
we weren't as concerned about when you
think about the racial
biases in the workflow we weren't
concerned about
that level of bias in the data because
we basically used all of the data
um and i should also add that um we are
doing work right now
to think about um
so we we we have the historical model
before we
implement the model into the real
into the the live app we actually use
um historical data um
a year's worth of data before that um
but
with kovid we've gone back and
rebuilt new models um because
we were concerned about some of the bias
you know the patients that were coming
into the hospital during covid
were different than the patients that
were coming to the hospital 60 years ago
and there is a much higher proportion
of non-white patients for example and so
um
we have built new models
up in boston and we have built you know
new models
um here to take that into consideration
as well we haven't implemented the new
models the the latest cycle
the update cycle we haven't implemented
them up with boston yet but we have
built
new models stay in consideration coping
thanks yes dana
can you dana can you put your audio out
um your little faint
sorry is that better yeah it's much
better
wonderful thank you so much it's so
interesting to hear
about your work i had um two questions i
see one is similar to ben sanders in the
chat and that was
really interested in your your use of
participatory design and was wondering
what nurse's feedback has been if you've
had a chance to
share with them um about the bias that
you've discovered and what their
reaction was to that
and then secondly would love to hear
more about how you got
this is the real-time analytics working
in epic
if you're doing that and we'll work in
epic or outside and then feeding the
results back in
yeah that's that's great question both
of those so so um
yeah so ben um just answer your question
so we have um we have
provided that feedback you know i um i
have i also have an appointment
in the in the department of nursing
research so it's a
it's a nursing appointment
uh in the department of nursing and i i
actually go and talk to
nurses all the time different like uh
meetings um and uh internal
presentations and i have been presenting
some of this stuff
um i think that um the feedback
actually has been mostly positive uh
most nurses
i've never i haven't there isn't a nurse
that has said that so let's start at a
higher level so nurses are very excited
about concern on a high level
first of all very excited that we're
using um
nursing documentation and we're sharing
this with the rest of the
energy spy team so they're very excited
about that they're very excited that
we're doing rigorous research
we're doing randomized control trial
every nurse that i've i've
talked to about this bias has said
they're not surprised that's been the
feedback that i've gotten from 100
of nurses whether they're clinic bedside
nurses or nurse leaders
now i will tell you there has been
responses back
from higher level nursing leadership and
we're talking about at the vice
president level
about how sharing this with the world
might make
the hospital system look but the fact
that
we are we have done this analysis across
two hospital systems
um you know i've been able to make them
feel better about that this is a problem
that's not unique to their hospital
and and um and that uh
so they they so that it basically ended
there
um with the implementation in epic um so
we you know we um it's being
implemented as a smart on fire app in
epic right so it's got a smart and fire
launch
um and um i would say that we are using
there's only so we are using fire calls
for everything the just out of the box
fire calls that epic provides you can go
to their public site and see except for
medication administration
we actually have a custom call on the
back end
where we're pulling that data um because
for medication administration it's just
a nightmare to um
to get it um uh in the way that we want
it
um but um but we but we are we are using
the medication administration
record uh call on the front end um
uh where you see the app uh where you
see the front end
data um so i don't know so it has been
fairly
you know there are some small things
configuration wise that the epic
documentation
said they could do that we had to like
find some workarounds but
it's been fairly well supported in epic
um one of the problems we do have is
just
uh trying to coordinate
uh the rollout of different predictive
analytics
um so in the screenshot for example i
showed you
um the circles are around we actually
ended up going with square circles
because there's another predictive
analytics
tool that comes out of the box and epic
that should that gives you back round
circles
so those are some of the things that we
ended up having to change after we
went live um
thank you so much
um there's any other there's another
question in the chat
um i believe from homer chen um
it's the it's it's the one above ben's
and and maybe actually you might want to
take a look at ben's and see if there's
anything you want to add to that okay
yeah so ben asked about the features in
nlp so
um so we did some work and you can you
can um
it's out there um and we worked with um
actually um dr um
dr lee up in um luzow
in uh up at partners she has an nlp lab
she was trained here at columbia so
she's one of our
columbia informatics folks but um uh we
did some work with her lab
um where for the nlp um
as i mentioned before you know we use
the
uh the ccc concept so it's a
ccc has a set of nursing
uh procedure and diagnosis concepts
and we took those concepts and we and we
what we're pulling out the nlp
is mapped to what clinical nurses said
are concerning concepts
so we have i believe 52 concepts
um and um what the nlp is giving us
basically is the prevalence of those
concepts
in the notes and those are those are the
features that we're using
in the rest of the model with some of
the other features so
um so we're looking at the prevalence of
those concepts in the notes
that's for the that's for the concepts
in themselves we're also looking at
just uh a raw count of notes and when
they're written
those are other features that we've
created that have shown signal um
uh and so i mentioned nurses right
nurses write notes at
specific times during the day specific
note types
and so if you see a nurse writing an
additional progress note for example
in the middle of the night um there is a
big signal in that
because there um so so um so yeah
i don't know if that answers your
question homer but that's that's how
we're
and and and dr zhao's lab has built
uh they have a they have a whole process
that they
they have a whole suite that they built
for
actually um identifying those concepts
labeling them showing them to clinicians
having clinicians wait wait them um and
then
extracting the prevalence and so we use
their tool
we've actually um built
we've uh we've actually built our own
process now because their tools actually
a lot more complicated than needed so we
have a simpler process to just
a simpler set of code that reproduces
reproduces that
well great um i i don't know if there's
anything you want to
um add um i know that dana had mentioned
that her question was similar to
ben sanders question but it is in the
yeah dana did i answer both of your
questions
yeah okay great um so the only the only
other thing i'd add about concern that
you know we also
we're we're gonna be doing some work
with um university of colorado
um they have a lot more you know all
both of the sites here are urban sites
um they have um virtual nurses that help
nurses say in other states that are at
much smaller hospitals they have some
hospitals they're like 25 bed hospitals
where everybody is on the same floor
like you know it's pediatric it's adults
it's everything
and those virtual nurses help the nurses
at the site
monitor patients so that's a different
use case
and we are we are going to implement
concern in that use case for the virtual
nurses
and we are curious to see if the um
on a virtual setting if the same
levels of bias still
hold we also are really interested in
concordance between
the nurse and the patient racial
concordance
we're trying to get to that data um
we're trying to get to the the clinician
um race data
to do an analysis for that too so that's
just some of the other stuff we're
trying to do
great um well we're we're uh a little
bit
we're at the hour so um i want to um
thank dr
cato for giving us a very informative
talk
and um interesting discussion afterwards
and clearly there are so many directions
this research can go
so thank you for virtually visiting
ohsu and and hopefully someday we'll be
able to have you
out so thank you so much and i
i i look forward to being there in
person someday
great okay take care everyone have a
great day